your co-star Natasha Leone who I just uh
handle on the boat
I know well actually she left you a
little message she was here and she
wanted to share a fun little fact about
you take a look at this oh God one thing
you might not know about my dear friend
Taylor Schilling hello Taylor is she's
kind of a terrible driver in most
conditions but for some reason when we
were together in Puerto Rico she was
actually terrific at driving we'll never
know why she's so bad at driving in Los
Angeles and so great at being in charge
of all of our driving activities in
Puerto Rico
foreign
that was fully out of necessity that was
necessity as the mother of invention I
mean I we were left to the wolves
I know exactly what she's talking about
it was also not a car it was a golf cart
and that was also at a moment in time
where I had been
um
fired from a rental car rental company
in L.A she's a rental car company yeah
yeah they were like we've had enough of
your there were Shenanigans shenanigans
on the road there were just a few little
like you know bebops you know just
with people you know too many dings well
okay so I heard the story about you
um is it true that you had to audition
um and kiss a mannequin yes it was some
sort of commercial audition and it was
very it was probably like in this some
Warehouse I don't know where how oh yeah
I don't know why I know I know
so I was it was some thing where I
walked it was four men and I was the a
park bench was set up and then a
mannequin like a dummy like a store
mannequin uh-huh and they were like skip
across the bench
and leap into the mannequin's arms let
it hold you
and make up with it and be in love with
it
I was like sure why not I didn't I
didn't get the job so in honor of that I
just thought that
I I you're gonna oh my God
this is
you totally get the job and you know in
a series of interesting pivots
um
I was up last night
um watching Dear Edward your new show
which I have to say also is getting so
much tremendous Buzz it's on
it is I was so excited it's on every
must-watch list for the year the season
you name it it's re and and now watching
it and having seen it I really
understand why it is um it's everything
it it pulls at things
um that I wasn't expecting it it's a
roller coaster thank you
[Applause]
this is your story you you tell it well
it's a story it's so it's we it's it's
just it's based on this book dear Edward
um so uh there is a plane crash there's
one lone survivor he's a a 12 year old
boy and I play a woman who his aunt and
her whole family dies she's in this
process of trying to get pregnant have
it have her own child and isn't able to
and it's kind of a a story of healing
through community and how we really need
each other I mean you guys I see why
this is on every Must List I'm so glad
it's getting the critical recognition
that it deserves actually have a clip
here I wanted to take a look at that
I for one I'm missing work not to
mention I left Edward home with my
husband which is basically like leaving
a 12 year old boy alone with a man who I
love dearly but is also essentially a 12
year old oh hold up did you say a 12
year old boy named Edward is it the
Edward
he's putting two and two together here
are you the aunt
yeah yeah that's me I guess I'm the ant
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I can't wait all right we're gonna
do just do it I hear you're a a good
drawer I mean I like I like to draw I've
had moments that's all we need
foreign
[Music]